اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا
نحييكم الى بانوراما نناقش فيها كالعاده
ابرز ملفات اليوم
والسبب امريكا خلاف نستراتي ام انه يتعلق
فقط بالتنسيق بين البلدين في الملف الثاني
مؤسسه القرض الحسن
الله تتوسع بمناطق جديده في لبنان الهيمنه
على النظام المصرفي ام هي حيله جديده لغسل
اموال المخدرات كما يقول مراقبون وفي
الملف اسئله
على استبعاد المحكمه العليا احد وزراء
حكومته التصعيد ام الانصياع
ونحيكم الى تفاصيل مخاوف كبيره من
احتماليه حدوث تصدعات او بالاحرى انتكاسه
المحتمله بين برلين واشنطن والسبب دعم
اوكرانيا عسكريه المانيا تشتريت ارسل
دبابات الى الجيش الاوكراني لمواجهه
القوات الروسيه بان تتخذ الولايات المتحده
خطوه مماثله وفقه مصدر حكومي الذي اشار
الى ان المستشار الالماني
عده على ضروره ارسال الدبابات الامريكيه
الى اوكرانيا مقابل تصدير بلاده دباباتها
من طراز لوبر اثنين والتي يرى خبراء في
مجال الدفاع انها الانسه للجيش الاكرانيا
لكن موقف البيت الابيض حمل في طريقته
رسائل مبطنه في اشاره الى ان كل دوله لها
حقوق اتخذ قراراتها السياسيه بخصوص
مساعدتي اوكرانيا دون تدخلي طرف ثالث وه
شدد الرئيس الاوكراني للقدسه السياسيين في
اجتماع المنتدى الاقتصاديه العالمي على ان
امدادات الاسلحه الغربيه يجب ان تاتي
باسرع وقت ممكن
[موسيقى]
هناك الشهاده الملف الاول مع ابو يوسف
مصطفى العمار عضو مجلس امناء حسب الاتحاد
المسيح الديمقراطي وخبير الامن الدولي ومن
هيوستن عبر سكايب احمد الحنطي الباحث في
شان الامريكي اهلا بكم اسم حالي ان ابدا
من الجانب الالماني لفهم مدى خطوره هذا
التطور في الواقع البعض يتحدث عن ان
دبابات لوبرتو اشعلت فتله ازمه بين برلين
وعشق ولكن ااه ما درجات قساوه واثقا هذه
الازمه
استاذ مصطفى هل تسمعني
طيب ممتاز كنا نتحدث عند
مصطفى تسمعني الان صحيح طيب هذه الدبابات
نتفق على انها اشعلت فتيل الازمه بين
المانيا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولكن
هل لهذه الازمه ان تعطل مسار العلاقات بين
الطرفين
مساء الخير عليكم
طبعا هذه الخلافات هي تقريبا ابتدات عندما
استلمت بن السيد ولا بشوز الكابين
السياسيه هناك اختلاف وهناك مثل ما تعرفين
ايضا ضغوطات الداخليه على السيد نحن في
المعارضه حزب الاستديو لكن طلبنا قرار ان
يكون توضيح الى هذه المباراه او توضيح الى
هذه الخلافات التي ربما لا نعرفها الى
الان لكن غدا يوم غدا سوف اعتقد سوف تنتضح
لنا الرؤيا خصوصا هناك اصبح وزير الدفاع
جديد لقاء همم لقاء سوف يكون في رامز لكن
هذه الخلافات هي لا اعتقد انها خلافات
بسبب ليوبارد اثنين لكن اعتقد ان السيد
يقول لك هو يريد ان يبحث عن مبرر للخروج
من هذه الازمه لكن الى الان لا توجد اي
رؤيه واضحه وما هو نوع الخلافات
ان يخرج تماما من موضوع الحرب الاوكرانيه
ومسانده الغرب لهذا الحرب
نعم هو لا يريد ان يكون في الواجهه ودائما
عندما يتكلم يضع المسؤوليه على الجميع لكن
عليه ايضا ان يتخذ قرارات لانه ايضا هو
هنا يحكم كحزب حاكم يحكم ايضا سياديا الى
هذا البيت يجب ان يكون الرؤيه واضحه
اللقاء الذي مع السيده ارسل له الفندق
لاين قبل ساعات كان ايضا لربما نتائج سوف
تظهر بعد قليل لكن نحن نعول على ان يكون
اكثر فعلا موقف واضح من قبل السيد يوم غدا
خصوصا مع تنصيب وزير دفاع وزير الدفاع
جديد لربما انه سوف يكون بمستوى الطموحات
والمسؤوليه التي تطلبها المانيا ان يكون
ايضا مشترك مع الدول الاخرى
اوكرانيا سوف تنتصر دون دعمها عسكريا
وايضا دعمها انسانيه لكن الى الان
جد مهمه في الواقعه لما تتحدث عن ان هذا
الموضوع اخطر او يبدو ااه لابعاد اكبر
بانه لا يقتصر على هذه الدبابات وانما هو
موقف الماني مما يحدث استاذ احمد سمعت الى
ضيفي هل يمكن ان ترى حضرتك كذلك هذه
التطورات بهذه الرؤيه بان الموضوع قد فات
الدبابات الى همم هذا التحالف التحالف
الغربي او تحالف الغرب مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
انا لا اعتقد ان الموضوع يعني خلاف خلاف
استراتيجي او خلل في التحالف ونعتقد انه
الامر اقرب للتنسيق الامن هذه ليست المره
الاولى التي نشهد مثل هذا الخلافه التي
تذكر قبل اشهر حدث الخلاف حول طائرات كانت
همم يعني هناك مطالبات انه دول الحلفاء
الموجودين يعني في اوروبا طائرات الصخور
الموجوده لديهم الى اوكرانيا وكان هناك
شرط انه امريكا تعوضهم بطائرات امريكيه
ولم تتم يعني العمليه لانه من الواضح انه
لا يوجد رغبه في تقديم هذا نوع من السلاح
لاكانيا الاشكاليه في هذه الانواع من
الاسلحه لانها ليست اسلحه دفاعيه بحثت
تستخدم في الهجوم ايضا اوكرانيا تقول انها
تحتاج للدبابات الهجوميه لتحرير اراضيها
بينما يعني امريكا ومعها حلفاءها لا
يريدون ان يصل
التصعيد الى اقرب معين لان كانت تتكلم عن
القوه النوويه في صراع القوه النوويه
دائما انت لا تريد للطرف الاخر يعني ان
يخسر كل شيء تريد ان تضع له مخرجا ليحفظ
جزء من ماء الوجه لكي لا يضطر الى قلب
الطاوله على راسه جميع لا تتفق سيد مصطفى
صحيح
والعكس المعطياتي جدا مغايره هناك اكثر من
خمسه عشر الف قتيل ذهب في هذه الحرب
هناك ايضا يوجد همم تدمير البنيه التحتير
الاوكرانيه هناك لاجئين اكثر من تقريبا 10
مليون في الاتحاد الاوروبي هناك امورهم
معطيات للاسف جدا مخزيه فكيف وبالمناسبه
هذه الحرب ليس فقط على الوكران هذا الحرب
هي على اوروبا فاعتقل يجب ان يكون للسيد
ولا فروزن يكون له ايضا قرار سيالي صحيح
نحن في النار صحيح نحن همم نتعاون مع
الحلفاء والاصدقاء لكن هذه الحرب هي
تقريبا تبعد كيلومترات همم عن المانيا
واذا سقطت اوكرانيا بالكامل ايضا سوف تسقط
بالرنين ايضا كان ايضا وتسمى التي هي
رئيسه لجنه الدفاع من حزبراني ولها مواطن
جدا واضح هو صريحه هناك اختلاف داخل
الائتلاف الحكومي للسيد اذا نحن في المعرض
بعيد عن المعارضه لكن هناك اختلاف هناك
هناك تقريبا
اكثر الكره التي اسمها مذكره اصدقاء
اوكرانيا خلال ليتم ايضا اطلاقها غدا في
مؤتمرنشتاين ومن ضمنها المانيا لكن
ها موقفها هذا بابي حتى طلبنا نحن في حزب
الاستديو ان يكون على وزير الدفاع الجديد
للسيد الذي استلم مناصبه همم اليوم تقريبا
طلبنا منه ان يكون همم ان يكون له همم
نقطتين واضحتين النقطه الاولى هي اولا
تزويد اوكرانيا بالياباني اثنين النقطه
الثانيه ان يكون مندمج مع الجيش الالماني
الذي تم اهانه لسنوات الطويله خسر ما عملت
الساده قبل ايام او السنه الماضيه كانت
تقريبا هو همم مثل ما يقولون يعني كارثه
همم
لا يوجد هناك الى هذه الى المهندس الاسم
وهذا ايضا يؤثر على مستوى المانيا مع
الشركه والاصدقاء خصوصا في النهايه
استاذ احمد همم يبدو بانها ستنعكس سلبا
على التحالف على هذه الحرب على هذه
التحالفات الغربيه هو يقول بان ليس هناك
موقف محدد في داخل الامريكي داخل الالماني
ولكن على الاقل هناك مواضع همم
تظهر للعموم بان هناك تردد الماني او
اعاده حسابات المانيه تجاه ما يحدث في
اوكرانيا كيف ترى حظرتك هذا هذا التصعيد
كما يقول مراقبون
يعني اعلم كثيرا بما يحدث داخل المانيا
ولكن عندما ننظر الى الصوره بشكل يعني
بشكل اكثر همم توسع هذا ليس شيئا جديدا في
موقف المانيا منذ بدايه الحرب المانيا
تقدم رجل وتاخر رجل لانها ربما هي الاقرب
بين الدول الكبيره التي تاخذ هذه الحرب
وبالتالي لديها حسابات قد لا تكون موجوده
لدى الجميع بنفس المستوى همم
يعني بان هذه الخلافات تتعمق شيئا فشيئا
هذه لو لاحظنا دائما الخلافات تكون حول
الجزئيات محدده للجزيئات الاكثر حساسيه ال
ال المانيا لا تريد ان تظهر
دباباتها داخل داخل روسيا من يستطيع ان
يضمن لالمانيا ان اا فعلا هناك يعني سلسله
قياده وتحكم في القوات الاخرانيه تضمن ان
كل جنديه تحرك بناء على توجيهات القياده
لانه هناك يعني فصائل كثيره تحالف في
اماكن مختلفه والقياده
ليست بالضروره محكمه بشكل تام لكي تضمن
عدم حدوث مثل هذه الاخطاء او هذه
التجاوزات التي قد تضع المانيا في موقف
محرج امريكا ايضا لديها نفس الهاجس ولكنه
امريكا تحرس لا تريد ان يظهر خلافات على
الصوت ان يظهر كل شيء يعني متسق حتى لو
كان هناك
حتى لدى امريكا نفسها همم هذا صحيح سيد
مصطفى المانيا لا تود رؤيه دبابات له برده
دخل روسيا
اللي اعرف هذه وجهه نظر مين اذا كانت وجهه
السيد ولا فلوس
انا عملت مع الدفاع الامريكي
لسنوات طويله قبل سابقا كانت ستراتيجيات
غير عن ما نراه الان الان هناك تهرب البعض
يريد التهرب من المسؤوليه لكن الحقائق
الموجوده
ساعدوهم بابرنس وهي دبابات الامريكيه
اختلاف من يوجد داخل المعركه غير عن من
يوجد خارج المعركه نحن هنا نعطي فقط
لكن الموجود داخل المعركه اذا كان هم
الاخرانيين والجيش والجيش الدفاع
الاوكراني كل ما يطلبه هو يحتاج الى الى
اسلحه يحتاج الى ادوات يحتاج الى صواريخ
يحتاج الى مضادات الطائرات اذا لم يوفره
هذه الاشياء لم سوف لم تكن هناك نهايه الى
هذه الحرب بوتين لا يريد الانسحاب من
اوكرانيا بوتين لا يفهم لغه
الحوار ان تكون لهم فعلا يعني بوادر لحل
هذه الازمه لكن تركنا الباب لمده طويله
لاجل النقاش لاجل التحاور والدبلوماسي لكن
هناك شيء واضح العالم اعتقد اصبح اكثر
وضوحا بعد ايام
يكون تقريبا عام كامل على هذه الحرب هناك
شيء
واضحين لا يريد الحوار دبلوماسين هو فقط
يعرف انه حل هذه الحل الوحيد لهذا العرب
هو القوه نحن نتعامل بالقوه لسه سنوات
كانت معهم مثل ما يقولون صحيح وضحت هذه
الفكره ولكن سنختم بمحاوله لقراءه
المستقبل الاستاذه احمد اذا ما ضربت
واشنطن عرض الحائط بهذا الفيديو الالماني
هو ما كانت الاوكرانيين من دبابات له برده
همم كيف سيكون شكل العلاقه الالمانيه
الامريكيه وشكل هذا التحالف
لا لا لن يحدث هذا بدون وجود اتفاق ضمنيه
يعني من المانيا همم امريكا تستطيع بكل
بساطه ان تقدم عدد رمزي من الدبابات رمزي
نحن يعني نعرف ان تصريحات الامريكيه التي
تدخل ان الدبابات عبر رمز غير مناسبه
للاستخدام في اوكرانيا بسبب نوعيه الوقود
وبسبب التقنيه هي هي تبريرات مقنعه ولكن
كنا متقدم عدد رمزي يعني لتقديم غطاء
للالمان اذا كنت تريد ذلك
المشكله ستحل اما اما بتقديم الدبابات
بطريقه فيها موافقه سواء علنيه من المانيا
او او اي صفحه هذا الامر لانه لا امريكا
ولا المانيا تريده فعلا
مصطفى العمار عضو مجلس ومناه حزب الاتحاد
المسيح الديمقراطي وخبير الامن الدولي